my producers want me to be a little more
hip to the pop culture so they've
introduced me
to this new show the masked singer i
guess it's not a new show it's new to me
though
and they want to see if i can guess who
the singer is
so apparently this person is broadly
kind of in the political
cultural space so i'm gonna i'm gonna
apply all the skills
that i've amassed through all all the
work commercials
all my investigative skills all my
political analysis and i'm gonna guess
who the singer is let's roll all right
what
celebrity is behind such an imposing
dramatic costume
leaning
okay here's the t when people see me
they always see a winner baby but
while i've graced the cover of many
magazines i've
actually hidden behind a mask for most
of my life
even from those that i love the most
like my superhero death
it taught me how to shoot for the stars
so i did
and eventually millions saw me as a
superhero
but the more i focus on pleasing others
the farther i got from who i really was
my dad was proud of what i did but i
often wonder
if he'd be proud of who i am i'll never
know
oh they're little phoenixes i missed
many chances to tell him my truth
and it's my biggest regret but it taught
me
there's no time to waste so tonight i'm
not stepping back
it's bruce jenner right it's gotta be
this channel still knows
how to turn heads
uh it's not like a formal guess yet i
want to hear
wake up in the morning feeling like
bruce jenner
or caitlyn jenner 100 i don't even i
don't even
see the rest of it because see the trick
of this is that
it's gonna be they're saying i'm a
superhero or whatever so you're thinking
i don't know is it like
someone who played batman or something
or no it's not
because the real superhero the real
person deep down inside is caitlyn
jenner
[ __ ] her up buckaroo because
caitlyn jenner is the greatest female
athlete ever in history
he won the decathlon no other woman has
ever won the decathlon i'm not here to
talk about my transition
i'm here to kick some [ __ ] ass i'm
all chips on the table it's bruce jenner
calendar
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah for sure there's no doubt
you guessed it
why did you decide to do the math singer
you know what i like
challenges you know i race cars i fly
airplanes it kind of
keeps you going something new something
different so for me it was fun
you can only work on the golf game for
so long there you go
there it is there is the culture folks
future governor of california caitlyn
jenner i had a feeling
because it you think okay only a certain
type of person is going to go on this
show they have to be a real show boater
i guess politicians and
media people just in general or that but
there are gradations here some people
want to have a little bit more of a
private life some people
are reality tv stars like caitlyn jenner
[Applause]
the issue with this show is it's very
degrading
but the party don't stop oh why are we
still here
it's a degrading sort of experience but
if you
well one if you're gonna be a man and
dress up like a lady
in public you know for for your now your
adult life
you're not so concerned about those
things generally and even more so if
you're going to live with the
kardashians you're obviously not worried
about being degraded
if you know how i feel why would you say
that i'm really honored
that i am really pleased i'm really
gratified that i was able to get this
one i do so poorly on the woke
commercial guessing this is good we're
gonna chalk this one up as a win
if you want to see more of these send
your your submissions in
and we will see you on the next review
[Music]
videos